well good morning everyone
and good morning demis i know it's like
1am in london so we thank you for your
solidarity and actually being jet-lagged
with us i hope you're fully caffeinated
like the room here in singapore
i am i am good um dennis let me just
start off with you know when we talk
about ai and deep mind this is all about
understanding the human brain and
actually how it works
how far along are we in that journey how
much do we still not understand about
our brains
so deep mind we the way we approach
building artificial intelligence is we
try and take some inspiration from how
the brain works um and what we mean by
inspiration we're not trying to copy how
the brain works but we're sort of
looking at the architectures and the
algorithms and the representations the
brain uses and then we're trying to get
some hints and clues about how the brain
produces intelligence and then we're
trying to sort of recreate those
capabilities uh in our machines
so that effectively uh our systems can
think and learn for themselves so
there's enough known about the brain
that we can do that but we of course
there are many open questions still
about how the brain works but there's
enough clues there that it's useful for
building artificial intelligence
should i look at it in percentage-wise
are we like five percent you know
understanding of our brain or is it like
30
um i would say you know it's it's
probably 20 to 30 percent um but it's
you know actually i think once we build
ai it will be helpful as a tool to to
finish understanding the brain um but i
think that 20 30 is still quite
indicative and quite useful um after all
the brain the human brain is the only
existence proof we have in the universe
that we know of um that kind of general
intelligence is possible
i want to talk about biology in a second
but how much do we actually interact
with ai in our day-to-day lives without
even realizing sometimes
yeah that's that's right i mean
artificial intelligence is embedded all
around us now every time you use your
mobile phone you look at maps to find
where you're going you speak to it with
your voice um there's ai underpinning
all of those everyday things now
um what's you know recommended that you
watch next on on you know netflix or a
streaming service all of that has
aspects of ai underlying those
algorithms so you know we're touching
artificial intelligence uh you know
pretty much every every minute by minute
in our daily lives i want to talk a
little bit about biology so your system
alpha fold is the solution to the
protein folding system a grand challenge
in biology for the past 50 years so why
do you choose
that thing to work on why biology and
why now
so when we started deep mine back in
2010 ai was you know not fashionable
like it is now in fact it was very much
the opposite it was very difficult even
to
to raise some seed funding and what we
decided to do actually initially was to
um prove our algorithmic ideas these
ideas about building general learning
systems that can learn from themselves
directly from data and experience we've
started to prove that out on games
because very convenient as a kind of
testing ground for our ideas so we um we
beat the world champion at go famously
with our program alphago
then chess um and then start a video
game called starcraft a teacher again
called starcraft and the idea was
ultimately always to eventually apply
those algorithmic ideas to real world
massive real world challenges
in both in commercial challenges but
also in science and alpha fold as you
say was our first big breakthrough in
science where
um we're able to
predict the 3d structure of a protein
which goes a long way to determining
what function it does in in life and in
our in our bodies and we're able to
predict the 3d structure directly from
its one-dimensional genetic sequence
which normally would take years and
years of very painstaking experimental
work to find and now we can do it in a
matter of seconds so isomorphic labs is
also your new company with a mission to
reimagine the entire drug discovery
process what can it achieve that humans
can't is it pace or is it actually new
discoveries
well we think that um you know alpha
fold is a kind of proof of concept that
some of these things some of these
aspects of biology and biochemistry that
used to be done painstakingly in the lab
in the wet lab
and take many many years and be very
difficult types of experiments a lot of
those things we think are ready to be uh
tackled computationally or ai first
and um and you know we think that if
it's not just the protein structure the
structure of a protein which causes only
one small aspect of of what you need to
do to to discover a new drug or a cure
for a disease there are many many other
aspects that need to be um need to be
cracked um but we actually think a lot
of those uh uh components in that drug
discovery process
are potentially amenable to
computational and ai first methods and
what we want to do with the new company
is kind of accelerate investment in that
area and really push that as far as it
will go and i think it could be very
exciting in time in the next five plus
years um where you know we might see a
new a kind of revolution in the way some
of those
um steps are tackled uh much much more
quickly and in the end um deliver cures
you know far faster than the kind of 10
years average that it takes today so is
that for the actual drug development or
finding the drug or is it also safety
because that's usually the process that
takes the longest so can you achieve
that quicker to make sure that it's safe
and so maybe cut yeah potentially both
those things so so part of it is is is
identifying the right target um then
it's sort of you know designing the
right compound the right chemical
compound to bind to that target um and
then also testing its properties so
making sure it's not toxic and has solid
the right solubility the right thermal
properties and so on
and we think that ai could potentially
predict many of those properties so then
when it goes to you know to the point
where it's going to clinical trial then
you have a much higher confidence and
percentage chance of getting through
that clinical trial uh and of course
that would extend it would also
accelerate that whole um discovery
process as well by potentially many
years
um there is people who work in
technology or like health tech often say
about a culture clash between software
developers that are interactive want to
go fast and maybe you know drug
development which has more checks and
balances how do you make sure that
there's not a culture clash
yeah no so i think of course um there
are many reasons for for medicine and
and and and farmer to be like it is and
obviously um you know you have to
carefully check all of your experiments
um before you uh uh obviously distribute
anything but i think there are many
steps in the in the early discovery
process um before you're anywhere close
to getting to market or doing the
clinical trials and and regulations that
come with that and all those kinds of
things where um it's purely sort of
scientific in the lab and it's those
steps that i think we're looking to see
if they can be accelerated uh and
enhanced and helped with um very comp
you know sophisticated deep
computational and ai methods much like
alpha fault
google's previous pharma 4a um you know
have struggled i'm thinking of the
partnership with sanofi aventis fizzling
in 2019 there was you know the contact
lenses that could actually check
whether you had diabetes or not what
will you do differently with this
project
yeah this is a very different sort of
project to other things actually i think
that's going on in pharma in general
where we're really focusing on the
computational side of things that's our
expertise from deep mind that's what the
expertise of the new company isomorphic
labs will have is um really doubling
down on this idea of modeling aspects of
biology how much of biology can we
computationally model can we understand
with information systems i think at its
at its most fundamental level biology uh
is an information processing system you
know you can obviously dna has often
been called as a sort of code you know
really like a code
but i think many other aspects of
biology
our cells proteins and other things can
actually best be understood as uh
information processing systems
and if that's the that's the right hunch
then a lot of these systems might be
modelable and predictable with machine
learning methods so it's a really
different um kind of approach to say
building devices or building wet labs
and other more traditional approaches to
things like drug discovery and medicine
um dennis are people at deepmind
concerned about the powerful ai that
you're creating being controlled by a
single entity do you feel comfortable
with that and are you know what are the
checks and balances that that you want
to make sure always in place
yeah we we're very comfortable i mean um
we've been now part of the alphabet
group for for nearly eight years um
we're very proud of that they give us a
ton of support we're an independently
sort of run subsidiary so we have our
own map our own um research agenda um
our own culture um and all of that is
and you know obviously we're based in
london um and so
we have a lot of freedom to operate uh
how we think best to sort of deliver our
mission uh of you know solving
intelligence and using it to advance
science and benefiting humanity and so
we're sort of laser focused on that and
um we sort of see it's the best of all
worlds really so we get to still sort of
be like a nimble i still regard us as a
startup even though
we're a dozen years in we still have
plenty to do in our mission um but we're
backed by
you know this really big entity
supportive entity and um and another
thing is we have a lot of collaborations
with google on the commercial side in
terms of our technology being embedded
now in hundreds of google products i
mean pretty much any google product you
use will have some aspect of deepmind's
technology um under the under the hood
um and
in terms of sort of ethics questions and
other things we've always
had the ethical use of ai as a
fundamental uh uh building block of
deepmind from the very beginning we plan
for success so we thought even back in
2010 when no one else pretty much was
working on ai we already envisaged how
powerful the technology could be
an extraordinarily powerful technology
with extraordinary opportunities but
also some risks that come with that and
so we had that in mind from the
beginning and we've embedded that in
everything we do you know we have
internal uh uh ethics committees and
other things that check uh and look
through with the researchers in
partnership with them um every research
that we work on um and deploy and um and
alphabet and google itself has also
publicly um uh declared their their sort
of ai principles which we're a big part
of um helping draft and and obviously we
we subscribe to those principles as well
are there lessons to be learned actually
from the social media industry about
risks and a reputation and is there
anything holding ai back are we you know
do we fear it or are we curious about it
yeah i think you know if you look at the
i obviously it's a very different field
from the from the social media um uh
field and industry but there are some
lessons there which is i think we we
should take on board about um building
very powerful technologies you know
perhaps building them with good intent
in mind and and some good theories at
the outset of what what they would be
capable of um but then when actually you
realize your um uh your ambitions you
also need to think at that point
but before it happens what the
unintended consequence might be and um
and i think for some some for powerful
things you know like social media but
also like ai um uh you know you need to
think about that ahead of time i i don't
think it's a good idea to sort of um to
use an anachronism of like you know move
fast and break things um you know that's
maybe appropriate for things like games
or apps or you know things like that but
i think for when you're talking about
powerful new technologies and certain
powerful new science i think a
scientific method and a scientific
approach was sort of thoughtful
reflection
thoughtful progress
critiquing everything you do
submitting your work to peer review
outside peer review which is obviously
the norm scientific method
all of those things help science to be
very robust and why it works so
brilliantly um and i think uh the
scientific method is more the correct
method and approach i think for um
building these types of powerful
technologies how much can ai actually
contribute to climate goals
yeah so actually we i've just come back
from cop26 probably like many of you and
i i i was talking there about the many
ways i think ai can actually be a really
big contributor uh to helping with the
climate crisis i think there's at least
three ways uh one is optimizing existing
infrastructure so um we did that already
at google where we um reduced the amount
of cooling
the energy the cooling systems within
the google data centers used by about 30
percent uh we've now generalized that to
um and it's available on google cloud
for um all building controls uh and
we're running a bunch of pilots and it
looks like we can save 20 to 30 percent
of the energy used by an office building
uh through more efficiently controlling
the air you know air conditioning and
and heating and so on so um you know
this could be huge if you think about
rolling that out globally um it's about
six percent of the world's emissions are
building office uh emissions so um i
think ai could optimize many existing
infrastructure which would almost be for
free because it's just software on top
of existing um infrastructure secondly i
think it's like better making better
predictive models of climate and the
weather we've just um built a rainfall
prediction system that's better than
anything the uk met office has um and
then thirdly it would be accelerating
new technologies so things like material
science um
also protein the works behind proteins
could help potentially and things even
like fusion and plasma containment we've
worked on so
i think all of those three areas could
be accelerated by
ai
there is what can contribute most to the
acceleration of ai adoption and
capability and i don't know whether for
example for alpha folds or isomorphic
labs you have a time frame on which you
want to you know solve certain
drug situations
yeah we always have like we always have
sort of near-term plans medium plans and
then very long-term plans we've had that
from the beginning we had a kind of
20-year plan when we started the deep
mind which we're about halfway through
now and and and on time the same with
isomorphic with i've with alpha fault
we've already open-sourced that and
released it free for any use commercial
or academic because we felt that was
actually the quickest way to get the
maximum benefit for the scientific
community and humanity and uh we
actually partnered up with the european
bioinformatics institute uh based in
cambridge and they built the best uh
database tools for the biological
research community and uh we hosted all
the predictions for um all 20 000
proteins in the in the human body so
that's the the human proteome it's
called is sort of um equivalent to the
human genome but but but with proteins
and uh that's all available along with
20 other multiple organisms so over 300
structure predictions are on that
database and um we've been really amazed
and and pleasantly sort of surprised by
how quickly uh the entire biological
research community uh has adopted that
in fact 300 000 scientists have already
accessed the database which i think is i
think there's only about 300 000
biological researchers in the world so
perhaps every single one of them has
already looked up their favorite protein
in in our database
so it's amazing to see that kind of
impact and then isomorphic is going to
sort of look more carefully specifically
a drug discovery process so things like
small molecule design
um binding affinities so more directly
to do with the drug discovery process
whereas alpha fold was more about the um
fundamental biological research
questions
demons how a final question how does the
ai first of all fit in the metaverse and
what's your ai utopia in in five ten
years
yeah so ai and you know metaverse is
actually a funny thing because um i feel
it's gone full circle with the metaverse
i used to starting my career before deep
mind designing computer games and
writing ai for computer games and
obviously the metaverse is the sort of
next evolution of of gaming in some ways
and i think ai's got a big place to talk
to play there in terms of creating
compelling avatars or characters within
the metaverse world that you can
converse with and interact with and
perhaps
advance stories and other things with so
i think actually there's a huge amount
that ai is going to bring to the
metaverse and ultimately you know i hope
my hope for ai is that we'll we'll use
it to over the next decade we'll start
seeing it really materially contributing
to some of the biggest grand challenges
facing us as a society from you know
disease to climate
dennis thank you so much for joining us
today
thank you thanks for having me